you are watching cold face Channel a
small footnote to the viewer this video
will not be a tinfoil hat video I'm not
going to be talking about how Google's
becoming too big and it's going to be
the next Skynet I'm going to give you
facts there will be some small personal
opinions within the summary at the end
of the video but that's it now please
enjoy the production 1995 I was five
years old and the public Internet was
only three years old people didn't
really know what the internet was or how
to use it or even if it was of any use
to them on one particular day in 1995
history would change forever a 22 year
old Larry Page and a 21 year old Sergey
Brin meet for the first time at Stanford
University Larry and Sergey soon become
good friends and begin collaborating on
a search engine called backrub in 1995
there are about 13 search engines to
choose from and they were all terrible
they didn't give back anything remotely
close to what you asked for
but backrub was different it had a
secret formula it was called PageRank
and you're looking at it now this one
formula was one of the reasons that
backrub performs so much better than the
other search engines of the time this
was the key the secret this formula who
indirectly be worth billions in the
future on September 15 1997 backrub was
changed to google.com and the rest as
they say is history
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Google the stuff you probably don't know
a lot of us just really see the surface
of Google we use their online services
like Google search Gmail YouTube and
Google+
every day many of us have a phone
featuring Google software and maybe even
Google hardware Google's self-driving
cars and augmented reality glasses a
cool but very few people ask themselves
the question how big is Google and what
else are they up to
let's find out please make sure you're
seated before you continue Google is
much bigger than you think
first we'll look at five interesting
Google acquisitions of the past but then
we'll look a bit deeper into some
revolutionary things that the company
has been doing over the past few months
number 5 Android acquisition date 17th
of August 2005 cost 50 million dollars
we all know what Android is and no doubt
the best part of Android is its open
source nature this allows the operating
system to be on anything from phones to
cars to fridges Android is everywhere
out of a 260 1.1 million smartphones
sold in 2013 211 million of them were
running Android that's over 80 percent
Android has allowed access for countries
such as China to really have a serious
shot at the smartphone industry let's
move on Google is obviously just more
than Android number 4 YouTube
acquisition date 10th of December 2006
at a cost of 1.65 billion dollars I will
do no justice to convey just how
mind-blowing the huge YouTube is the
facts will do this for me looking at
YouTube purely just as a search engine
it's bigger than Bing Yahoo and asked
all combined in fact it's the largest
search engine on the planet second to
only Google search itself so it's
obvious that people are searching for a
lot of things this only must mean
there's a lot of content on Nietzsche
but how much continuous video content
actually gets uploaded per day maybe a
week one month of continuous video two
months a year note try a decade that's
right over a decade's worth of video is
uploaded at a rate of 72 hours per
minute and that's just in one day it's
nothing if you start adding it up it
gets even stupider for one month just
one month there is four billion hours
worth of video watched each month that's
over four hundred and fifty thousand
years worth of video watched in just one
month and of course as you watched this
particular video on YouTube those rates
are increasing I could go on with the
facts but there's a lot more crazy stuff
to cover in this video number three
Motorola Mobility acquisition date 15th
of august 2011 at a cost of 12.5 billion
dollars Motorola Mobility was in trouble
in the early 2010's and Google used this
opportunity to get themselves into the
hardware side of the smartphone world
but halfway through the production of
this video something very interesting
happened
Google's sold Motorola Mobility to
Lenovo for 2.9 billion dollars this
makes it seem as if Google's interests
were elsewhere perhaps they just wanted
to hang on to some of the patterns that
they acquired from the acquisition of
Motorola to help Android defend itself
against Apple perhaps some court cases
in the future or perhaps the ones passed
number two Boston Dynamics acquisition
date 10th of December 2013 cost unknown
ok so this is where things start to get
a little bit crazy
remember those robots are showing you a
while back in that top 10 video Google
bought Boston Dynamics the company that
created the robotic technology if you
want to know more about these amazing
robots just check out the first YouTube
video link in the description below this
acquisition means that Google now in
some of the most advanced robotic
technology on the planet it doesn't end
there though number 1 nest acquisition
date 13th of January 2014 at a cost of
3.2 billion dollars nest labs previously
created some very beautiful smart
thermostats and smoke detectors as part
of their goal to create a conscious home
Google is going to help them do that in
a very big way we may eventually see a
home powered by Android and Google now
these kind of acquisitions will be quite
interesting at the next five years or so
and here's a bonus item deepmind
acquisition date 26th of January 2014
this was Google's first AI company
acquisition deepmind can be described as
a world-class groundbreaking technology
on the cutting edge of machine learning
they use systems neuroscience to build
powerful and general-purpose learning
algorithms but let's get to the Google
robot because it seems like they have
all the parts in place so let's dissect
a bit let's start with what would be the
brain of the robot and that is deep mind
we don't actually know that much about
this company but we know that it was
created by a child prodigy who like
chess and has gone on to create games
and we know that they have some patents
in looking at images their technology
and deciphering what's inside the images
without humans saying what's actually in
those images and then little critical
thinking exactly critical thinking as I
said earlier this video is not a tinfoil
hat video so the aim is not to scare
people so I'm going to tell you facts
according to official statements the
deep mind technology is going to be used
for google image search for now anyway
so that's a bit about what Google's been
doing what about some of the more crazy
out there stuff well there's definitely
some lesser-known things going on at
Google of course I'm mainly talking
about Google Apps Google X is a semi
secret facility run by Sergey Brin and
Astro teller Google X aims to
quote-unquote
improve technologies by a factor of 10
according to a straight are he goes on
to say think of science fiction sounding
solutions in late 2013 Google went on a
robotics company acquisition spree
everyday they purchased a new company
that operated in fields such as humanoid
robots robotic arms and computer vision
I guess we just have to wait for the
announcement to see what they're really
up to
another very interesting project is
Project loon Project loon aims to
provide Internet service for the four
billion people that don't yet have
access it aims to do this via balloons
in the stratosphere the balloons will
float in the stratosphere about 20 miles
or 32 kilometers above the Earth's
surface the balloons will create an
aerial wireless network with 3G speeds
it's hope that Project loon will bring a
low-cost way to get the rest of the
world online so as you seen some amazing
advances in technology are happening
right now it's an exciting time to live
anyway we'll take a short break and then
we'll be straight back after this every
day America Online is making it easier
for people to live work and play you
know I can even send email on the
internet and welcome back let's get
straight back into it recently Google
was part of a world-first event let's
check out the news bulletin from CNN to
see what it was this machine made by
Canada's d-wave will be installed in a
NASA Research Center in California yep
so as it turns out Google is also in the
quantum computing game now we've really
don't have enough time to go into all
the details of what it does and how it
does it but the bottom line is Google is
involved in one of the world's first
commercially available quantum computers
now performance wise it's not that great
for a quantum computer it's just a tiny
bit faster than a regular computer at
the moment but of course it's the very
first version of a brand new sort of
computing so it's gonna take some time
to get there but it's pretty cool that
chip you're staring at is an actual
quantum computer it's hoped that this
computer could be used in the future to
solve very complex optimization problems
one of which is global warming but of
course one step at a time
the mysterious barges in October 2013
for strange floating barges were found
off the coast of Treasure Island San
Francisco Ricker's Wharf Portland and
New London in Connecticut
Google refused to give any detailed
statements about the use of the four 250
feet long two thousand plus tonne barges
the only explanation given for the
existence was to in quotes to use the
barge as an interactive space where
people can learn about new
technology some say it's just a
storehouse or marketing area for Google
glass but no one knows for sure and now
I'll end off the video with the most
recent announcement
January 16th 2014 Google announced their
specialized contact lenses these contact
lenses will provide a glucose monitoring
system for diabetics using a non
intrusive method so over the next decade
we may see home automation from a
conscious house advanced intelligent
robotics and the global expansion of
Internet coverage but in ten years
just how much will Google own their
services may already account for almost
40% of all Internet traffic in one way
it's a bit unsettling to see a company
have such a large and growing embrace
over every aspect of the technological
universe but on the other hand it only
can be and it has to be Google that
advances the state of our world there's
no other company out there that has the
resources and infrastructure to do the
research and develop such amazing
technologies and produce products at a
reasonable price for the world the only
thing I ask of you Google is to just
stay sincere so you've just seen all the
latest information about one of the
largest most dynamic and influential
companies we're ever likely to see for a
long time so what do we take away from
all of this well you can look at it this
way the founders of Google Larry Page
and Sergey Brin were just two regular
guys to regular college dropouts to be
exact they saw a need and need for more
accurate search and they put their minds
to it and you have just seen the result
so the next time you feel like giving up
on an idea just think about that too
very intelligent but otherwise regular
guys changed the world so what do you
have to lose alright so I'm not a life
coach but it's still food for thought
so that was Google and this is men hey
to go get here the creator of this
channel and also that video of course so
if you guys are new here I've got some
music videos and some documentaries and
all sorts of other stuff because I'll
just do a little bit of everything
really so if you know someone that likes
google or technology in general and you
want to share this video you can do that
as well because no editing and putting
together and planning one of these
videos takes quite a lot of time not
sure if you could notice that or not so
just any little thing helps you know
people have been saying I should get my
stuff out there so this is my effort to
try and do that in there yes all I
really wanted to say all right so I see
you again for the next one and enjoy
your day Cheers but I so it's all in
good fun and hopefully you guys enjoyed
it and I'll see you again soon for the
next video don't know what I'm talking
about